elles sont huit 8 femmes d'exception a
participé aux premiers tedx saint denis
où mène le tad x est un concept importé
des états unis il permet à des personnes
de prendre la parole devant un public et
de partager en direct des idées le thème
a été créée en 1984 états unis et la
personne qui a inventé cet événement
vous voulez tout simplement que des gens
qui ont des idées super intéressant bas
que ces gens-là partage devant un public
intéressé au point même de néophytes et
a ainsi les gens qui peuvent assister au
tél il rompt le lendemain ou plus tard
partager les idées qui ont été partagés
et ainsi ses idées pourront être
propagée à travers le monde tout
simplement
et il faut savoir que toutes ces idées
qui ont été diffusés depuis 1984 sont
sur plateformes telles qui compte plus
d'un milliard de vues sur youtube
pendant 12 minutes les intervenantes
part de leur vécu de leur vision de la
femme dans notre société
les parcours de vie parfois difficile
mais toutes ont un message d'espoir des
idées qui peuvent aider à changer nos
comportements
moi je voulais faire un tas
d'aujourd'hui que j'ai constitué avec
toute mon expérience pour mes enfants
pour les femmes en devenir pour beaucoup
de peur que je vois sur toujours hésité
à franchir le pas et à se dire j'existe
je ne survit pas c'est n'ayez pas peur
de vivre
ne regrettez pas votre base et aimez
votre futur provoqué votre avenir
croyez en vous croyez au meilleur
laissez-vous une chance aux éboueurs
confiance
j'ai surtout voulu partager aujourd'hui
que nous sommes qu'en et créons ce que
l'amour ne se l'amour neurones ne
jalouse pas l'amour et serviable l'amour
est charitable
sachons aimer les uns et les autres pour
ne former qu'un dans la vie comme ça
peut-être que nous aurons un petit peu
moins de violence un petit peu moins de
méchanceté envers les uns et les autres
un petit peu moins de ladi lafé qui
n'est pas toujours très bon un petit peu
moins de beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de petites choses négatives et
que nous allons aller vers uniquement ce
qui est beau ce qui est merveilleux ce
qui est magnifique à une centaine de
personnes est venue assister à cette
conférence qui se tenait à l'université
de la réunion
la première fois j'ai assisté je dois
vous avouer que je suis très
agréablement surprise c'est vraiment
quelque chose de formidable de voir des
gens partager leurs expériences et
surtout ne pas avoir peur de passer des
messages et ça c'est vraiment très ou
très très bonne chose mais on a des
témoignages très fort mais en même temps
cette générosité cette envie partagée
qui est fantastique jour une phrase un
vécu qui est vraiment un pacte en est
par exemple quand le premier speed ce
qu'on a vu il y avait sept cette dame
qui venait qui est originaire de
roumanie qui dit souvent son père lui
disait
quand tu as en prison tu as deux chemins
devant toi sois tu choisis la lumière
divine t'ouvrir aux autres en vo ou soit
autant de temps dure 6 et ça c'est très
impactant quoi c
et voilà tu retiens ça en tête et c'est
sûr que quand tu sors de là un peu
changé la sem des graines exactement
donc c'est ça qu'on est venu chercher
aussi le tedx une nouvelle façon de
partager ses idées qu'elle soit pour le
développement économique caritatives ou
personnel l'important c'est le message
qui mérite d'être diffusé
et de s'en inspirer pour aller vers un
monde meilleur